Trascrizione: Francesca Balla
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Iniziamo con una buona notizia:
non c'è nessun pianeta da salvare.
Siamo noi che abbiamo bisogno
di essere salvati,
per poter continuare a vivere
in questo meraviglioso pianeta
chiamato pianeta Terra;
ma che se noi guardassimo dallo spazio,
in realtà chiameremmo Pianeta Mare,
o Pianeta Oceano,
perché le sue dimensioni
sono sette volte ricoperte -
quindi sette decimi -
sono ricoperti da blu, da oceano, da mare.
E per questo adesso vi chiederò
di fare un esercizio, due respiri insieme.
Adesso, tutti insieme, facciamo il primo.
(Respira)
E poi facciamo un secondo respiro.
Ecco, questo secondo respiro
ci è stato completamente donato
dal mare, dagli oceani.
E dovete immaginare
che anche metà del primo -
perché solo la metà del primo
arriva dalle foreste,
e quindi dalla fotosintesi
clorofilliana delle piante.
In realtà, il 70 percento
dell'ossigeno che respiriamo
arriva da un'altra fotosintesi,
da microorganismi che abitano
i nostri oceani,
e quindi sette decimi del pianeta:
si chiama fitoplancton,
e fiorisce letteralmente in tutto il blu
che ricopre la nostra terra.
Ed è nutrito dalle balene,
il suo nutrimento viene dato
dalle migrazioni delle balene
che con le loro feci
le trasportano in zone remote,
con i loro tuffi rimescolano
enormi colonne d'acqua.
Ed è per questo che noi
dipendiamo dalle balene,
per vivere in questo pianeta;
noi dipendiamo dalle api,
dipendiamo addirittura dai vermi,
perché se muoiono i vermi
muoriamo anche noi.
E se muoiono gli oceani
noi ci estingueremo,
è semplicemente così.
Il fitoplancton è diminuito
del 50 percento, negli ultimi anni;
e questa percentuale
corrisponde all'ossigeno,
abbiamo un 40 percento in meno
di ossigeno, negli ultimi 50 anni.
Proprio perché sta collassando
l'equilibrio che sostiene
il nostro pianeta.
Questo che vedete è un "Medi-cane",
così chiamato: "Mediterranean Hurricane";
è il motivo per cui sono qui
con voi oggi a Bassano.
Io ero tra quelle due regioni,
Sicilia e Calabria, con delle navi.
Abbiamo iniziato un'operazione,
si chiama "Operazione Siso",
prende il nome da un capodoglio,
un capodoglio che purtroppo muore
per colpa di una rete, rete illegale,
chiamata "spadara":
sono reti vietate da 40 anni
dalle Nazioni Unite, vietate dall'Europa,
vietate secondo le leggi italiane.
Uccidono balene, capodogli,
delfini, tartarughe.
Sono lunghe decine di chilometri.
E nel 2017 il corpo di Siso, appunto,
si è spiaggiato a Capo Milazzo,
ci ha portato negli occhi
la prova del reato.
Noi, da quel momento,
abbiamo iniziato a lottare,
a combattere con delle navi,
armate di passione e di volontari.
E siamo riusciti, anno dopo anno,
ad aumentare il numero di navi,
e aumentare il numero di volontari;
fino ad arrivare a quest'anno,
dove siamo riusciti in quello
che era il nostro intento,
e cioè a fare la confisca più grande
insieme alla Guardia Costiera,
insieme alla Guardia di Finanza,
insieme alle Autorità italiane.
Abbiamo confiscato
17 chilometri, alti 42 metri,
di questi muri della morte,
portando a zero il numero di capodogli
che ogni anno, prima, invece,
era uno, due, fino a tre.
E quindi quest'anno, nel Mar Mediterraneo,
i nostri capodogli e le nostre balene
hanno nuotato libere nel loro mare,
senza reti che le abbiano uccise.
Ed è per questo che ho portato un video
per portarvi un po'
con noi, nelle nostre navi.
(Video)
Sea Shepherd difende e protegge
i nostri mari da 44 anni:
lo facciamo con navi,
passione dei volontari,
e le telecamere per portare
agli occhi di tutti
le distruzioni, i massacri illegali
dal Mediterraneo all'Oceano Atlantico
fino all'Australia,
e poi di ritorno fino all'Oceano Pacifico.
Ed è proprio lì che,
200 anni fa, inizia una storia,
una storia da cui possiamo
avere ispirazione.
Si chiama "Affondamento di una nave":
non si festeggia mai
un affondamento di una nave,
tranne qualche raro caso.
Questo è uno di quelli,
dove un capodoglio,
dopo aver visto massacrare
la sua famiglia e i suoi cari,
l'intera sua comunità,
ha deciso di non girarsi dall'altra parte,
ma di guardare l'arpione,
la baleniera che aveva ucciso,
riempito di sangue la sua comunità,
e di attaccarla,
di speronarla letteralmente,
di colpirla fino ad affondarla.
La storia ha dato il nome "Moby Dick"
o "Mojoadick" a questo capodoglio,
ed è il momento che noi
prendiamo ispirazione,
perché toccherà a noi
non pensare di essere degli ecologisti
che devono salvare un pianeta
che non ha nessun bisogno
di essere salvato,
ma invece di diventare dei lottatori
che cercheranno di salvare
la propria specie.
Lo scenario attuale è uno scenario
dove il mare Mediterraneo
è il più sfruttato al mondo:
sette specie su dieci sono sovrapescate:
vuol dire semplicemente
"over fishing" in inglese,
che scompariranno prima o poi,
cioè vengono pescate
più di quanto riescano a riprodursi.
Se ci aggiungiamo
il surriscaldamento globale,
sappiamo che i grandi
allevamenti intensivi
non sono assolutamente più sostenibili,
il carbon fossile,
e nemmeno gli allevamenti in mare;
quello dei pesci in mare
è un allevamento di pesci
che mangiano altri pesci.
Immaginate, quindi:
bisogna pescare il selvatico
per alimentare l'allevato,
un ossimoro.
Immaginate che per allevare un tonno,
per ingrassare uno di questi
famosi tonni rossi a Malta,
in questo momento
sono dentro delle gabbie,
servono cinque chili di pesce selvatico
per fare un chilo di tonno rosso.
Aggiungiamo l'inquinamento ambientale,
quindi i riversamenti di petrolio,
aggiungiamo l'acidificazione del mare;
e poi, in ultima, aggiungiamo la plastica
che, ormai, non solo è ovunque nel mare,
ma le micro plastiche, le nano plastiche,
sono in ogni animale,
che sia terrestre, marino o d'aria.
Ed è per questo che è
una nostra grande responsabilità,
in questo momento,
prendere ispirazione
per fare le nostre scelte.
Qui a Bassano del Grappa si è combattuta
la Seconda Guerra Mondiale.
Mio nonno abitava vicino al Ponte Vecchio,
qui a Bassano;
io sono nato qui a Bassano,
e mia madre era una partigiana.
Con lui combatteva:
mia madre era una bambina
e portava nelle sue trecce i messaggi
dal fronte nel Monte Grappa
fino a qui nel paese.
Loro sono considerati degli eroi:
noi possiamo vivere in un paese libero
grazie a questi eroi.
Adesso tocca a noi, venire ricordati
dai nostri figli o dai nostri nipoti
come dei pazzi scellerati
che hanno distrutto il loro modo
di vivere, la loro civiltà,
oppure come degli eroi
che hanno scelto di cambiarla,
e di lottare per la sopravvivenza
della nostra civiltà.
A voi la scelta.
Grazie.
(Applausi)